ten minutes past six year on good day
las vegas parents
you know how hard it has been this
school year distance learning has been
taxing on you
it's been taxing on your children well
now the discovery children's museum has
set up a new program to help
underserved students try and navigate
the challenge of distance learning
we have hector mejia live this morning
with details on that hector good morning
good morning john and we were inside the
last hour but they had to sanitize the
desk i was using earlier so now we are
outside
i'm just kidding we're just showing you
uh different parts of the museum here
but joining us live we have laura to
explain this new program
and so essentially what you guys have
done is transform
the vacant traveling exhibit hall into
different classrooms for students good
morning to you good morning
thank you for being here yes we
transformed our traveling exhibit space
into five really spacious classrooms for
our students and so
we have the capacity to serve up to 50
students
and up to 10 students per classroom and
for those families wondering how they
can be a part of this
what's the process like and what do they
have to do
we're currently serving the reinvent
schools so families
who have students attending reinvent
schools can simply reach out to their
child's teacher
guidance counselor or principal for more
information
laura it's a really neat idea especially
for those students who
don't have a place to go and just stay
at home maybe by themselves
it's really a neat idea how did he even
come about
well once we realized the need for
distance learning support in the
community
we reached out to our community partners
because we value collective impact
and they responded we're currently
partnered with
the las vegas philharmonic unlv tech
truckers the library district
and americorps just to name a few let's
take in the whole valley that's right
they're all providing supplemental
learning for our students
so our kids are here for a number of
hours pretty much
all day how do you keep them engaged our
educators are fantastic we have museum
presenters in the room with them
along with americorps volunteers and
they really
help keep the students on task and in
between direct instruction
the students have the opportunity to
explore the museum floor
or work on learning kits so families and
children are you know dealing with a lot
right now what have you been hearing
from families
uh we've really been hearing a lot of
great feedback from parents they feel
that this is
a really engaging and playful atmosphere
and most importantly that it's a safe
place for their child to be
all right thank you for having us we
have a lot more to talk about though so
we'll be back in half an hour from now
for now reporting live hector mejia 8
news now back to you
hector thank you very much parents
certainly looking for ways to try and
keep their kids entertained these days
so
yeah very important 613